[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
metri Serin schönen guten Abend
Christian noch einmal schlafen dann gibt
es hoffentlich eine schöne Bescherung
gegen Spanien guten Abend warten wir es
ab so sieht unser Team Überblick aus
Leben in Trümmern und unter Beschuss
immer mehr Ukrainer fliehen aus herson
immer weniger corona-regeln bürgertests
werden zurückgefahren ein weiteres
Bundesland hebt die isolationspflicht
auf
und zwischen Hoffen und Bangen deutsche
Fans zittern dem zweiten Spiel der
DFB-Elf entgegen
[Musik]
kein Wasser kein Licht keine Heizung
nach den russischen Angriffen auf die
Infrastruktur fehlt es den Menschen in
der Ukraine am nötigsten immer noch sind
mehr als 6 Millionen Haushalte ohne
Strom diese Zeit der Entbehrung der Not
erinnert viele heute an eine leidvolle
Zeit von 90 Jahren heute nämlich ist der
Tag an dem die Ukraine an den
sogenannten Holodomor erinnert eine
Hungersnot besonders auf ukrainischem
Gebiet wohl gezielter beigeführt vom
Sowjet Diktator Stalin bis zu 4
Millionen Menschen starben ganz aktuell
in Not und unter Beschuss sind die
Menschen im süd-ukrainischen Herren und
von dort berichtet jetzt Henna
Hebestreit
über den Fluss nipro schießen russische
Soldaten täglich bis zu 100 Granaten
nach der Sonne sie terrorisieren die
Einwohner die sich gerade noch über das
Ende der Besatzungszeit gefreut haben
jeden Tag gibt es Verletzte und Tote
unter der ukrainischen Zivilbevölkerung
spielen sich Dramen ab
ich hasse die Russen diese Leute haben
mir das wertvollste meines Lebens
genommen
das sind meine Eltern
ich muss jetzt überleben für meinen Sohn
niemand weiß wo die nächste Granate
einschlägt weil die Russen vor ihrem
Abzug große Teile der kritischen
Infrastruktur gesprengt haben lassen
sich im evakuierungszelt immer mehr
registrieren die weg wollen
wegen der andauernden Angriffe oder weil
sie Angst vor dem kommenden Winter haben
in diesem Zelt können sie erstmal zur
Ruhe kommen und überlegen wie es für sie
weitergeht
wir können sich die Menschen Aufwärmen
ihre Mobilfunkgeräte aufladen und im
Internet surfen wegen die Kälte gibt es
Tee und Kaffee
in der ganzen Ukraine wollen sie 4000
solcher Zentren einrichten die sie
Punkte der Unbesiegbarkeit nennen eine
große Herausforderung wird in den
nächsten Tagen auch die Verlegung von
kranken und pflegebedürftigen
Henna Hebestreit ist inzwischen wieder
in Odessa Henna es gibt Orte an denen
Betroffene Ukraine sich aufwärmen können
deswegen gibt es auch Spannungen
zwischen silensky und Klitschko was
steckt dahinter
ukrainische Präsident hat die
Einrichtung von etwa rund 4000 dieser
Punkte der Unbesiegbarkeit wie man das
hier etwas pathetisch nennt angeordnet
beauftragt damit wurden unterschiedliche
Behörden das ist der Katastrophenschutz
aber auch lokale Verwaltungen und in
Kiew geht es ihm offenbar nicht schnell
genug damit dort sollen 600.000 Menschen
in diesen Anlaufstellen versorgt werden
können eine Herkulesaufgabe angesichts
der schweren Zerstörungen in der
kritischen Infrastruktur dort mag seine
Kritik aber auch damit zusammenhängen
dass es zwischen den Präsidenten der
Ukraine und dem Bürgermeister von Kiew
menschlich sagen wir mal nicht so ganz
rund läuft und hat bei diesem ganzen
Stress dieser Streit vielleicht auch
seine menschliche Komponente danke für
die Hintergründe nach Odessa Henna das
für uns
unabhängiger werden vom russischen Gas
das ist ja eine der leeren aus dem Krieg
in Europa sollen dafür auch neue
Gasfelder erschlossen werden es gibt
beispielsweise in der Nordsee 20 km vor
Borkum ein großes Erdgasfeld 60
Milliarden Kubikmeter Gas werden dort
vermutet die Niederlande wollen es
fördern aber dagegen gibt es Widerstand
denn die Förderung im Watt mehr birgt
Risiken dazu Ulf Roller
sie sind gekommen um das Wattenmeer vor
der niederländischen Küste zu retten sie
sehen sich als Kämpfer gegen den
gashunger in Europa und für den Schutz
der Natur denn die Niederlande suchen
nach neuen Energiequellen Shell will im
Wattenmeer ab 2024 nach gasbohren
hier fördern wollen wird die
Energiekrise nicht lösen denn es steht
erst in drei Jahren zur Verfügung
wir müssen die Natur schützen jeder
Mensch braucht sie zum Leben das Gasfeld
liegt unter Wasser 5 Milliarden
Kubikmeter will Shell jährlich aus dem
Watt mehr Punkten diese Menge ist etwa
der Gasverbrauch Deutschlands in sechs
Wochen das auch Gas erhalten soll die
niederländische Regierung verteidigt das
Projekt wir brauchen die Gasfelder unter
dem Watt um unsere Energieversorgung und
die für Europa sicherzustellen
wenige Kilometer entfernt liegt die
Provinz Groningen dort lässt der
niederländische Staat schon seit
Jahrzehnten Gas aus dem gesteinsboden
fördern Erdbeben erschüttern immer
wieder die Region kaum ein Haus ohne
Schäden viele Dörfer gleichen Baustellen
sie hat einen Schaden denn die sind aus
Backstein die Mauern reagieren auf die
Erdbeben und die Bodenbewegungen
seit die Energiepreise steigend
diskutieren Sie in den Dörfern wieder
mehr Gast zu fördern auch wenn alle
unter den Folgen leiden da sie Menschen
geraten in Panik wenn es an ihr
Portemonnaie geht
die Angst vor den Kosten und um die
Umwelt in Groningen diskutieren sie wie
überall über den Preis des Gases
die USA befürchten Sabotage und Spionage
und verbannen deshalb
Kommunikationsgeräte chinesischer
Hersteller vom US-Markt betroffen sind
unter anderem Geräte von Huawei und ZTE
sie stellen ein inakzeptables Risiko für
die nationale Sicherheit da so die
Begründung der
us-kommunikationsaufsicht die USA werfen
Huawei enge Verbindungen zu chinesischen
Behörden vor
gestern erst hat der Bundesrat
zugestimmt dass im nächsten Jahr
deutlich mehr Haushalte Wohngeld
beantragen können heute warnen die
Kommunen es könne bis weit in den Sommer
dauern bis alle Antragsteller den
Mietzuschuss auch bekommen man habe
nicht genügend Leute um die Welle von
Anträgen schnell abzuarbeiten sagte Gerd
Landsberg vom deutschen Städte und
Gemeindebund der Bild-Zeitung zu Corona
das Virus im Blick und im Griff haben
das hat sich Deutschland ziemlich viel
kosten lassen und schon über 16
Milliarden für Tests ausgegeben so kann
das nicht weitergehen fordern Kritiker
schon länger und wurden jetzt erhört ab
heute gilt nämlich der Staat zahlt nur
noch in bestimmten Fällen für
Schnelltests in welchen das weiß an
seinem Stern
Winter mit Virus auch in diesem Jahr
aber mit immer weniger Antivirus regeln
das Testen wird jetzt weiter reduziert
den Abstrich kostenlos bekommen auch in
Zukunft etwa Besucher und Beschäftigte
in Kliniken und Heimen oder Menschen die
pflegebedürftige zu Hause betreuen die
schnellen Tests für drei Euro etwa vor
dem Konzertbesuch oder der Familienfeier
werden gestrichen sinnvoll sagen wir
rollogen
hier gilt natürlich der Grundsatz für
Kranke soll zu Hause bleiben dadurch
wird sehr sehr viel kann sehr viel
verhindert werden auch an
übertragungsereignissen hier ist
allgemein festzuhalten dass eben eine
breite Testung asymptomatischer z.B in
allgemeinbevölker also symptomatischer
Menschen nicht mehr empfohlen wird wenn
man tatsächlich Corona hat ist das mit
dem zu Hause bleiben so eine Sache da
sind die Regeln wieder mal
unterschiedlich in immer mehr
Bundesländern müssen sich infizierte
nicht mehr isolieren seit heute gilt das
auch in Rheinland-Pfalz
ich finde es ehrlich gesagt gut ich
glaube das ist ein ganz schwieriges
Thema und am Ende des Tages muss jeder
für sich selber entscheiden ich glaube
jeder hat eine moralische Verpflichtung
der nachkommen soll ganz schlecht ist
der
Bundesgesundheitsminister der hat ja
versucht sich durchzusetzen aber hatte
keine Chance
Karl Lauterbach kritisiert das Ende der
isolationspflicht scharf mehrere
Bundesländer machen es trotzdem Streit
um den richtigen coronaweg das bleibt
auch in diesem Winter
sie wissen weil es so viel Chaos bei der
letzten Berlin Wahl gab wird im Februar
neu gewählt die Parteien kämpfen längst
schon wieder um Stimmen nach letzten
Umfragen liefern sich die Regierenden
von SPD und Grünen aber auch die CDU
einen Kopf an Kopf Rennen besonders
dringendes Thema das würde heute auf
einer Demonstration deutlich ist die
Bildungs- und Schulpolitik aus Berlin
berichtet Stefan Merseburger
am Nachmittag treibt sie eine Mischung
aus Sorge Wut und Verzweiflung auf die
Straße Eltern und Lehrer beklagen den
Zustand der Berliner Schule zu wenig
Lehrer
zum himmelschulen die geräumt werden
müssen
abstürzende Fenster und einen riesigen
Sanierungsstau sie hoffen von der
Politik gehört zu werden am 12 februar
wird gewählt heute Vormittag
Landesparteitag der CDU Spitzenkandidat
Kai Wegner will Bürgermeister werden er
bemängelt eine bildungsdauerkrise seit
über 26 Jahren hat die SPD Verantwortung
in diesem Bereich Berlin steht sehr
schlechter in den ganzen Vergleichstest
schneidet Berlin immer ganz weit hinten
ab wir haben zu wenig gut ausgebildete
Lehrer und viel zu wenig Schulplätze
viele Schulen sind in einem
beklagenswerten Zustand neue
Bildungsstätten werden gebaut doch das
dauert Mann tue was man könne so die
Regierende Bürgermeisterin es sind in
den letzten fünf Jahren über 25000
Schulplätze geschaffen worden und wir
werden in den nächsten fünf Jahren
weitere 25000 Schulplätze schaffen dafür
haben wir eine schulbauoffensive 2
Milliarden Euro sind vor gesehen für
dieses und nächstes Jahr auch die grüne
mobilitätssenatorin Bettina jarasch will
das Rathaus erobern für die schulmisere
sei Koalitionspartner SPD zuständig die
Debatte über das was es für gute Schule
braucht ist leider angesichts der
Riesenmenge die es in der
Bildungsverwaltung seit vielen Jahren
gibt völlig unter die Räder gekommen
grüne SPD oder CDU wer auch immer das
Rote Rathaus gewinnt braucht zum
Regieren einen der beiden Konkurrenten
schauen wir nach Italien dort hat ein
schwerer erdrutschteile der
Mittelmeerinsel Ischia verwüstet eine
Frau kam ums Leben mehrere Menschen
werden noch vermisst Starkregen hatte am
Morgen eine Lawine aus Schlamm und
Geröll ausgelöst mehrere Gebäude wurden
zerstört Straßen waren und passierbar
die schlammmaßen behoben Häuser unter
sich und schoben mehrere Fahrzeuge ins
Meer
einen Erfolg für den Artenschutz melden
internationale Umweltorganisationen aus
Panama da haben Vertreter von 184
Staaten zwei Wochen lang verhandelt und
beschlossen das 470 weitere Arten unter
besonderem Schutz stehen etwa Frösche
Schildkröten und Echsen auch rund 100
high und Rochenarten dürfen künftig nur
noch nachhaltig gehandelt werden der
Verkauf der wegen ihrer Flossen und
ihres Fleisches begehrten Tiere wird
stärker kontrolliert
morgen um 20 Uhr deutscher Zeit Anstoß
Spanien gegen Deutschland dann beginnt
das große Zittern weil man nach der
Auftaktniederlage schon mit dem Rücken
zur Wand steht und der Gegner außerdem
Spanien heißt kein Spiel und keine WM
wie jede andere und das spüren auch die
angereisten deutschen Fans in Katha
Wolfgang Zimmermann berichtet
wir gehen jetzt ins Stadion wir gehen
Dänemark schauen sich mit anderen
deutschen austauschen das passiert in
Doha wohl nur hier an der fanbotschaft
es gibt sonst keine typischen
Treffpunkte keine fan-märsche zu den
Spielen überhaupt sind nur wenige
deutsche da aber die optimistisch 2:1
und dann sehen wir uns im Finale in am
18 dezember und ich hoffe halt dass
unser Trainer da irgend so eine
Wundertüte rauszieht wir treffen hier
auch Band Kunkel den bei einem Spiel
seine regenbogenbinde abgenommen wurde
für den Fall hatte sich auch
Innenministerin Faser beim Besuch hier
interessiert gestern hat die FIFA den
Regenbogen in den Stadien dann ja doch
für Fans zugelassen super schönes Gefühl
dass man sich dafür eingesetzt hat und
das jetzt dann tatsächlich auch
durchgedrungen ist dass die FIFA dann
noch mal mit Nachdruck betont hat das
ist jetzt auch offiziell erlaubt ist und
man fühlt sich dadurch ein bisschen
weniger beobachtet Katha für viele Fans
eine ganz neue Erfahrung es ist anders
aber es macht Spaß wir haben das halt
perfekt organisiert hier man merkt auch
dass hier sogar wenig fußballradition
herrscht was mir auch gefällt ist dass
man wirklich Menschen aus aller Welt
trifft und die haben deutlich weniger
Probleme mit der WM als die Deutschen
ich glaube schon dass die ganzen
westeuropäischen Fans das sind ein wenig
von dieser Unbeschwertheit die
normalerweise da ist weg ist einfach
aufgrund des Austragungsortes man merkt
das glaube ich schon bei den asiatischen
Fans bei den afrikanischen gerade auch
bei den südamerikanischen Fällen scheint
es überhaupt keine Rolle zu spielen
und so sieht das dann aus wenn
argentinische Fans ihrem Spiel entgegen
fiebern für ihr Team geht es heute um
sportliche überleben wie morgen dann für
Deutschland
morgen das Spiel und schon heute gibt es
schon wieder Wirbel ums deutsche
team-kostüm Stichwort Pressekonferenz
bei der PK saß Hansi fliegt der
Bundestrainer allein wobei die
fifa-regeln verlangen dass auch ein
Spieler am Tag vor dem Match dabei sein
muss der DFB nimmt eine mögliche
Geldstrafe in Kauf das Team soll er sich
komplett auf das Abschlusstraining
konzentrieren
das Positive zuerst alle sind fit alle
machen mit beim Abschlusstraining auch
Leroy sané ist nach überstandenen
Knieproblemen wieder eine Option für den
Bundestrainer der tatsächlich die Qual
der Wahl hat denn seine erste Elf muss
diesmal nun wirklich funktionieren das
ist das schöne ist ja daran dass man
mehrere Positionen ist auch ein bisschen
offen hat das zeigt natürlich auch eine
gewisse Qualität die wir haben und
deswegen lasse ich da schlafen immer
schön eine Nacht drüber morgen früh
glaube ich bin dann ein bisschen
schlauer nach einer Nacht ohne solche
Albträume bestenfalls aber auch so wird
haben sie pflegt die Abwehr umbauen
vielleicht bringt er ja sogar Josua
Kimmich als rechten außen Verteidiger
und in der Offensive möglicherweise
einen reinen bayernblock auf jeden Fall
ist es das wichtigste Spiel für haben
sie flicke als Bundestrainer es ist ein
Finale das erste finale für uns in
dieser in dieser WM und wir haben einen
Plan wir hoffen natürlich dass der
Morgen aufgeht
Reifeprüfung oder raus aus dem Turnier
uns dann morgen die Frage
Sven Vossen Katha alle beim Training
keiner zur PK ist das ein Zeichen von
Nervosität
ja aus Sicht des DFB würde ich sagen
alles richtig gemacht denn man wollte
keinem Spieler zumuten die anderthalb
Stunden zur Pressekonferenz nach Doha zu
fahren und wieder zurück denn das
Abschlusstraining vor dem wichtigsten
Spiel des Jahres ist das wichtigste
Abschlusstraining des Jahres und da
braucht man alle 26 Spieler und haben
sie Flick wollte letzte Erkenntnisse
sammeln für seine Aufstellung kann Leroy
sané vielleicht sogar von Anfang an
Spielen er hat auf jeden Fall voll
mittrainiert und trug blaues chinesio
Tape am Knie das soll beruhigend und
kühlend wirken vielleicht etwas dass die
ganze Mannschaft gebrauchen kann vor dem
Showdown gegen Spanien morgen ab 20 Uhr
im ZDF vielen Dank Sven Grüße zu dir
nach Katar die polnische Mannschaft
feiert Robert Lewandowski der mit seinem
ersten WM-Treffer den 2:0 Erfolg gegen
Saudi Arabien besiegt hatte in der 82
Minute beendete der Weltfußballer vom FC
Barcelona seine Flaute und traf in
seinem insgesamt fünften WM Spiel
endlich ins Tor was für eine große
Erleichterung für den
[Applaus]
in der Gruppe D hat Australien den
ersten Sieg bejubelt 1:0 gegen Tunesien
und ward seine Chance auf die erste
achtelfinalteilnahme seit 16 Jahren und
Weltmeister Frankreich zog als erstes
Team in die Ko-Runde ein die
equiptricolor tatsächlich gegen Dänemark
lange schwer bis Kilian im pappé mit
seinem zweiten Treffer in der 86 minute
den 2:1 erfolgt sicherte
und wir haben noch was schönes vom
Wintersport bobolympiasieger Francesco
Friedrich ist in Wissler Kanada mit
einem Sieg im Zweier in die
Weltcup-Saison gestartet so viel Zeit
muss sein Dankeschön ja trübe
adventsaussichten gleich von Katja
horneffer dazu etwas Regen und ganz
wenig Sonne um 22 Uhr meldet sich
Marietta Slomka mit dem heute journal
morgen hier Barbara halweg für sie noch
ein schönes Adventswochenende und auf
bald
[Musik]
guten Abend Auslöser für die kräftigen
Regenfälle zum Beispiel auf Ischia war
dieses Tief das jetzt in der Nacht über
Sizilien und Malta weiter südwärts
ziehen wird bei uns in Mitteleuropa ist
das Wetter deutlich ruhiger das Hoch
Florian zieht morgen weiter nach Osten
und das Tief Yoki bringt hier im
Nordwesten etwas Regen mit heute Nacht
wird sich zum Teil dicker Nebel bilden
besonders in Süddeutschland aber auch im
Osten dabei sinken die Temperaturen an
den Küsten und auch hier wieder rein auf
recht milde 6 bis 4 Grad sonst geht's in
den Boden Frost tauglichen Bereich
zwischen plus 3 und -7 Grad und dann
kältesten wird es am Alpen Rand Bayern
bleibt auch über Tag sehr kühl da liegen
die Höchstwerte oft nur bei zwei bis
vier Grad sonst werden meist sechs bis
zehn Grad erreicht und wie mild es wird
hängt ganz entscheidend davon ab wo sich
der Nebel auflöst das wird morgen nicht
überall der Fall sein zum Teil bleibt es
trüb Chancen auf Sonne haben sie am
Alpenrand aber auch hier im Nordosten
von Nordwesten kommen Regenwolken heran
und die erreichen bis zum Abend etwa
Kiel Hamburg Hannover und Köln und
ähnlich trüb geht es dann auch in den
nächsten Tagen weiter von Osten wird es
etwas kälter schönen ersten Advent